ساعات قليله تفصلنا عن ضربه بدايه
المونديال والعالم يترقب الافارقه بطبولهم
والوانهم العرب بحماسهم وهتافاتهم المدويه
والبرازيليون من شوارع ريو وسو باولو
ومناطق المشجعين في كل مكان على كوكب
الارض السابعه بتوقيت الدوحه ينطلق كاس
العالم 20 22 اخيرا في المنطقه لاول مره
وبمشاركه اربعه منتخبات عربيه قطر الدوله
المضيفه السعوديه تونس والمغرب استاد
البيت بمدينه الخور يحتضنوا صفيره بدايه
اكبر حدث كروي ورياضي في العالم وللمره
الاولى بعيدا عن فصل الصيف نسخه تتوقع ان
يتابعها اكثر من نصف سكان الارض نحو خمسه
الجماهير العربيه دخلت اجواء المونديال
بالفعل منذ السابع بالاعلام والهتافات
والمسيحات على كل حال نتمنى التوفيق لكل
المنتخبات العربيه المشاركه وبانتظار
النتائج الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يعطينا
مؤشرات
[موسيقى]